since you mentioned earlier that you do
other things not just act you also
producing right how do you balance all
that I mean in terms nice yeah well it
makes me feel like I'm doing stuff like
successfully on all fronts there is a
bounce there's a I think the acting like
I said earlier it's kind of like some of
it's a little out of your control you
know you can go a lot of days on the
calendar without having a good audition
but if you're stood at home you don't
really have an excuse as a writer for
not writing so you can always kind of do
do stuff so I think there's that type of
balance and for me personally I haven't
got I've produced a couple things but
the majority of the stuff that I produce
I've had a hand in in the writing or on
the creative side so balancing like that
it can you know if the acting is not
happening during this month year decade
whatever I can still fall back on that
because that's I hold power at least to
write it down and for most of what
you're writing they're mostly webisodes
or now you're transitioning more to mom
yeah like every right everyone has their
plethora I've done a bunch of blog post
for random sites out there that have
gotten picked up but short form sketches
the web series is more like a you know
five think of a five minute TV episode
so it's more of a linear line and then
the company I write with now is features
so I've written feet like anybody that's
a writer you you know their first
feature is not the one that goes it's
their hundreth that they've written so
I've written a bunch before but this was
the first one where I had more of a more
of a structure or more of a business
plan behind it and more you know outside
help and more eyes on and I'm huge with
collaboration like oh that idea yeah
that's better than Milan I'm gonna write
it though and steal it will not steal it
but my name is on it I don't know who
I'm talking to over there so it was
really it was a really cool interesting
thing with this new company that I've
been writing with because it was like
they set out a plan they're like alright
here's like almost like a book like with
the publisher like here's when we need
the outline here's we want the first
draft here's when we're gonna do our
first table read doesn't have to be
perfect let's just see what we have by
that and so it's constantly going back
and forth with notes and how it could
work you know keeping in
and if this went we need to keep in mind
this budget you can't write a you know a
movie that takes place on Mars with
what's expensive to make fifty thousand
fifty thousand dollar check for my
hypothetical friend they gave it to me
and I invested it in a camera
you